[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i mean not that long you know about an
hour just a long time that's a long time
for an
aunt and who are you i'm rhett there you
go see you forgot that part you did
screw it up no you interrupted me and
i didn't you said i could tell in your
eyes you weren't going to say
your name who said not that long of a
time
what's your name i interjected what if
we had what if
it was a custom like a cultural custom
in america that you could only say your
name when
asked i kind of feel
like a vampire could only enter when
invited yes i feel like that would be a
good
societal rule because instead of people
coming in really
i'm rut it'd be like i only want to know
your name if i ask
what's your name and i'm linked this
week at the round table of not as dem of
lighting because we're
still in the alternate creative house
location maybe permanently i don't know
we are discussing we're bathing in the
aftermath of our
separate prequel vacations
separate but equal vacations uh
potentially identical
vacations i know we both went to beaches
we both endeavored to surf uh-huh we
took our families
we both took our families we both came
back with one less family member
oh that's a tease no i
i i took a head count before and i took
a head count case i always take a head
count
oh crap you're right i'm a left shepherd
i'm like a chaperone
counting heads on the wall i have an
extra family member right now because we
have a
we lock as a friend who's been living
with us for i don't even know how long
it's been now
so i so i know what it's like to have
three kids i've had three kids for
two months is he pulling his weight he
does
more than both of my children combined
great he's very helpful
like what like about hiring him so he
does chores
he just is a more conscientious person
than my kids
so you're going and maybe it might be
because when you're trying them out for
a trade when you're when
yeah can you do that sure uh when
you are at some now this is what i've
been told
because i a lot of times i have parents
who i have parents who come to me and
they're like
you know locke is so conscientious or
he's really helpful and he's so polite
and he's a great conversationalist and
he offered to help with this and he said
thank you
i'm like we didn't do that at home
he's a jerk at home i i talked to i'm
not gonna mention any names but i
i talked to one of my children who
happens to be one of the
the oldest one who happens to be one of
the oldest
or the or the oldest one uh i kind of
feel like maybe i didn't center the shot
i think maybe
is there more of me in it i feel like
there's more
of i'm closer to the center and i didn't
do that on purpose that's not good
i mean because i feel like it's fine you
know what just go with it you've got a
little bit of
like i've got like a full six inches off
my shoulder
i'm gonna do a little adjustment just
keep going i can do it oh yeah you're
close to see
you're close the wrong way
too much it's too much you i think this
is pretty good that's way too much
i think that's it i think that's
centered um yeah
that's spoken like a
semi narcissist okay
stop how is that oh that's nice oh yeah
see it gets a little bit of the skin
wall in there
that's that's the little tip of the skin
you get a peak of the skin well that's
how you know you're you're centered
um i said you know we have the
discussion
hey i want to treat you i want you to
treat me
like you like you would treat your
friends
like at least at that level i don't i'm
not asking for the respect of a parent
all the time i'm just asking for the
respect that you would give
any other human being wow just a minimum
yeah of respect yeah it's like i hope
what i say is i hope you don't treat
your friends this way
oh i get that i don't want to talk about
this anymore because
i'll get in trouble i'll get more of it
uh yeah so we had our vacations
it's we we cam we came back with more
tan yeah yeah
i might you talk about the skin walls i
have bitcoin i'm looking at my
people have been noticing that you have
been been getting closer
to matching my skin wall which
incidentally i mean we didn't plan this
because we didn't know we were going to
record your biscuits in here but
we should have done the skin walls on
opposite sides because now you sit in
front of
my skin wall which is you know to the
naked eye
it's the same as your skin wall if
you're just in here looking at them side
by side you'll be like well that's the
same color
and we know one is lake house and one is
what's yours
um it's the guy's name chadwick brown
chad i don't know why i just came back
to you it came to
me man that's chadwick brown that's
that's lake house but you're looking
pretty lake house i'm looking pretty
chadwick brown
and i you know what it's i'm i'm i'm
rejuvenated and baked
yeah i mean i'm sunbaked um well and
interestingly so we we usually go on
vacations at the same time
because you know our lives are in sync
in a lot of ways and
if you go on vacation at a different
time when i'm out on vacation
and then that means why now i got to go
on vacation when you're not on vacation
and that's two weeks of us not being
together who knows what could happen in
those two weeks
one might think that we should stagger
our vacations in order to like
because there's a hope you know other
stuff that we give input on it's not
just being on camera together
to like run a company correct but we
just do that remotely
and we have very trusted people who
who can who can handle it for a week yes
which is great
maybe they can handle it for more maybe
we just what if we just
what if the default is vacation
i like where this is going i mean
let's face it what we're doing right now
is is still another form of vacation it
is
we're just you know we're in a house
there's no man this is work man look
working so hard you got your admiral hat
on hey i got a new hat that's one that's
one of the things i brought back i
didn't bring back another child i
already had one but
on escape i did bring back a captain's
admiral you call it
admiral's hat i like that on a scale of
one to ten
just to get into this how would you rate
your vacation and then dive in man we
got
i got a lot i need to report on i you
know there's
uh i got a story oh i guess
i got angry oh it to me
i'll let you rate first but when i rate
my vacation
it's there's a corollary to how many
times i got angry
either at other people or myself or just
just kind of just kind of lost my cool
or
uh my peace oh man that happened once
so i had a pretty good vacation if i can
only say that happened once
well okay so on a scale of one to ten
i'll tell you about it and i'm gonna
i'm gonna say that an uh an eight
is like what you bring the expectations
that you bring into an expectation yeah
you know what you don't expect a perfect
you know things some things are gonna go
wrong but you're kind of hoping you're
usually hoping for about an eight like
this is gonna be
better than my normal life right because
it's a vacation
and then in like nine and ten that would
be like i don't know if that's ever
happened
right four oh gosh
yeah i mean you had a brightness in your
eyes i wouldn't ask the question
i mean i thought i was lobbing you
something to knock out of the park man
no
no you freaking had a four out of four
that's not i mean
i mean it could have been i mean i had a
seven oh look
i mean it's not it's not a competition
i'm sorry
i mean we should talk about the covet of
it all before we get into vacation too
much because it's
i mean we had that contributed to it we
had planned vacations
i mean i was going to freaking disney
world
with my extended family and like
the first few weeks of quarantine of
course that got obliterated
and then i was gonna i was gonna go home
for july fourth and see the
the rest of my family that got
obliterated uh
i was gonna go up to santa cruz i had
booked a place up there
that was early on earlier on in
quarantine that got obliterated
and then it got to a point where it's
like i'm just not you know
we're at home we're going to be at home
i'm going to go into the office the
minimum amount of time with a minimum
number of people and be
absolutely safe as possible we don't go
out and do anything
and when we do we're doing the mask
thing i mean all of that is still in
full effect
yeah you're basically just staying at
home it's just a different home
so yeah so we we did like a an airbnb at
the beach
and uh so the with like their cleaning
certification
and then we just hunkered down there and
we went south and
uh i mean la at least right now is it's
one of the hot spots so technically
technically leaving la and hunkering
down somewhere else i mean you're
you're a little bit a little bit lower
risk you know
this is a hot spot man um
so but we are high risk going into that
place so for the
for the sake of everybody else but we're
not because we've been isolated here
now okay so it's like just being at home
at the house that we rented
wearing a mask all the way to the beach
to where we set up a spot
that is then well distanced
beyond six feet from anybody else and
then
um getting in the water i will just my i
was just
a lot of that was the game plan that's
what happened
a lot of
my experience the entire time
was man this this would be really
awesome if we weren't in a global
pandemic like that that's kind of i was
like oh that restaurant would be cool to
go into
that store would be cool to go into this
would be an awesome place to be but
there's this
you feel you know
there's this you're conscious of the
fact that
there's a pandemic going on and so you
never are
super relaxed until you're like seated
on the beach right the process of
getting to the beach it's like you're
just kind of thinking about things that
you typically don't think about and so
that's not what i mean that contributed
to it not being as good of a vacation as
vacations used to be before covet but
the main thing that happened to me yeah
if that i can't bring you to a four
because just be
i mean we're blessed to be able to
to go on yeah and we know that uh
but the thing is is that i have a
i have a problem i've talked about it
before and i think this is pretty common
like people
you tie expectations to things whether
it's a vacation
a project whatever but vacations are the
things that most people
tie a certain level of expectation too
and you think about it and you you fool
yourself into
thinking that like oh but when i go on
vacation
that's going to be a great week like oh
yeah that that
vacation week at the beach that man
that's going to be good
because that's the point of it and then
i started thinking things like
um well i got a
what am i going to do on the vacation
because i want to make sure that i'm
doing
the vacation well right and so then so
what
my sort of expectation was and first of
all i'm a lot more aware of this than i
was say 10 20 years ago
where i unconsciously went into
situations with all these expectations
and then i was disappointed
at least i've gotten to a point where i
know
the way my mind works is you have these
expectations you need to set low
expectations you need to go with the
flow but i just find myself getting to
the place where
i've still got the expectations and the
expectations for this vacation were
uh i want to actually i want to get a
lot of surf
time in right i want to surf but i also
want to get my kids surfing
pretty much for the first time lock it
down a little bit earlier in the summer
and you know me and you stand up
paddleboard
surf and i've had this secret hope
to be able to don't believe that count
to regular well
the the thing is is that there's lots of
places in the world that if you go
and you didn't bring your big ass paddle
board with you you just you you don't
have an option to surf
and then there's also a lot of really
cool brakes
uh where you're not really supposed to
you're not even allowed to be on a
stand-up paddleboard in some places so i
was like i would just like to have that
in my arsenal of abilities the ability
to like surf and i'm not talking about
like
you know hang 10 or catch big i'm
talking about like
old man on a long board like just the
bare minimum
catching away i get that you want to the
versatility so i was like okay
san diego it's it's it's it's an
easier surf town you know we were
on this various beaches between la and
san diego but we were closer to san
diego
and it's just there's a it's easier to
surf down there it's less territorial
there's more there's more places to surf
there's less people whatever
so i was super excited about that and we
were like walking distance from a place
that was
a good place to learn
and i took my longboard that
i bought you know this year down there
and day one i go out and uh
it's frustrating like it's it's
frustrating when you know that you could
be
already standing up on a paddle board
and surfing yeah
but you're sitting there trying to stand
up and like
not getting not balancing falling off
the board it kind of reminds me when we
decided to start snow skiing even though
we were both
pretty decent at snowboarding exactly
like i know how to do this you have to
invest
like a whole ski trip just to learn how
to do something where you could be
enjoying it do anything you already know
how to do
right so day one was pretty frustrating
there were a couple of moments of hope
and the reason you ski is because as you
get older it's like it's better on your
well it's harder on your knees easier on
your back for me that's why i
transitioned to skiing but
it's not good on the pelvis and that's
why i transitioned to stand-up
paddleboarding because it's easier on
the back
for me case in point day two i go out
and uh i'm gonna i don't know exactly
what is going on but one of the things
that has always happened to me
uh it used to happen before i would go
on a vacation or before there was a
significant transition or in the midst
of a transition
i would have my lower back act up and
basically
your back would go out go back to what i
call my ground zero injury which
is related to my herniated discs it's in
a very specific spot on the left side of
my spine and then
you know ten years ago when this would
happen
even five years ago when this would
happen i would be out
i would be in pain for months when this
happened now i've gotten to a place
where i can experience that injury and
then a few days later i'm pretty
functional whatever and now a week
later because i'm about to tell you i
did hurt my back um
but the second day i wake up
and first of all the the x factor of any
vacation is the bed right what is this
bed going to be like in this airbnb when
you got a bad back
you're very sensitive to beds in general
and the softer the bed
the worse it is on your back that's the
case for a lot of people with back
problems
i was like man this bed is unnecessarily
soft
i love a soft bed and i was like my bed
was too hard
i i could have swallowed like i almost
left on the floor
for most of the most of the time but i
didn't i just took there's a mattress
topper i took that off after the second
night
but uh got up that second day and i was
like man my back is tight but i did my
you know all my stuff that i do to
loosen up
lock and i go down to the beach and
second wave standing up and then i hear
i feel like oh there it is
oh no oh no oh no and then it's like a
it's a sharp pain but then i'm like okay
but no i'm in better shape let me just
go in i'm going to do some
stretches on the beach like an old man
so you so you rode two waves in the
second one
well i didn't ride the wave i was in the
process of standing up when it
went out on me and then you you fell
over and then i go
i swim in to the the beach i get on the
beach i do my stuff
and then it hits me very very squarely
and clearly
you're not going back out today and so
i like wave it like i'm like i gotta go
in he's like okay
he stays out there by himself i walk
back
to the house carrying my board which is
not feeling great because
i gotta walk like you know a quarter
mile or so with this board
my back is hurting because standing up
on a it's an explosive act
yeah to to go from paddling on your
chest
to like to standing up on a board i was
trying to show lincoln how to do that
because there were foam boards that
happened to be at the place we stayed
because i don't own any of those because
uh you know i'm i didn't want to make
that i didn't want to make that
transition but i'm like hey it's here
and i'm showing him on the beach how to
do how to stand up and
it's uh it's explosive it's and there's
there's twisting involved too yeah
you're turning what you're supposed to
be turning your
your hips i don't know i could imagine
that it could really
well but here here's here's the thing
ring your back
and you know i was talking about this in
therapy because
physical therapy i
i do you know i don't want to get into
too much woo
and i don't really know exactly what i
think about this but i do know that
there's a connection to emotional
sort of pain and stress that manifests
itself
physically in ways that we don't quite
understand okay
uh this has just been proven many many
times like i told you
every time i get ready to go on a
vacation or i'm in the midst of a
vacation
there were many years where i would my
back would i could
feel it tensing up right because it's
like the act of relaxing and
and it's very difficult for me to relax
on vacation we'll talk about that a
little bit more
lately later and uh
and so i think the act of trying
to relax a little bit plus the bed
plus the act of doing something i don't
know exactly what
the pie chart is that contributed to it
but it was the perfect storm
but all that to say i was immediately
deflated right
and again and it felt like because i was
like
can't surf the rest of the week that was
amazing i was like am i going to be able
to surf
paddleboard at all i'm not going to be
able to surf at all
for the rest of the week and not and
this is
you know a very privileged problem
but also i was upset because the airbnb
which came with a hot tub
the hot tub wasn't working and they were
like we can't fix it while you're there
because it's the manufacturer said it's
broken it has to be replaced or
something
so i was like oh my hurt my back and i
also can't get into the hot tub to make
myself feel better
you know so you're that's a four you
plummeted yeah and i was that lower than
a four
and and i was no well okay
so when it happened to me as i was
walking back to the house
thinking about the fact that my
expectations have been thwarted
i was like of course this is what has
happened
right because um what do you mean
i'm saying that like you think you
deserve it you deserve no no it's not
about being
deserving it's just like this is the
perfect
gift from the universe for someone who
is
who is bringing this level of
expectations if what you really want to
learn how to do
is to accept things to go with the flow
to not have all these expectations
tied up in your experiences but to let
things
happen to you to let things come to you
as a because even when i'm out there
surfing
it's very difficult for me to have fun
because i'm focused on doing it well you
know what i'm saying i'm like
you got to get up and you got to catch
this wave it's like i i approach it like
an
athletic event versus like yeah and
an enjoyable thing because there's this
part of me that's just like you got to
get good enough at this before you can
enjoy it
if you get good enough at it then you
can actually sit back and read the
benefits
the joy that comes from it so
long story short is my back got better
enough to stand up paddleboard
the very last day i had a really good
surfing day
caught a bunch of waves it was it kind
of redeemed the experience
but the fact that my expectations were
kind of ripped apart i didn't learn how
to do regular surfing
i wasn't able to surf even on a paddle
board for two days after i hurt my back
it was almost like the vacation was a
lesson
and lessons aren't fun so it wasn't like
oh i'm having an incredible time
doing the thing that i thought i was
gonna do i'm really just kind of sitting
here wishing that i was doing the thing
that i thought i was gonna do it's
interesting you say
lessons aren't fun but so do you think
that you would have enjoyed your
vacation more if you didn't see it as a
lesson
that you just said oh i have an injury
now i gotta pivot to just watching
netflix the whole time i'm here
uh well no when that's and i'll talk
about that i'm sure
because that is what i did and and that
created another
sort of weird but did the emotional
experience okay dang man
i'm very in touch with myself no
but seeing it as a lesson you said
lessons lessons aren't fun but
i actually think that this mindset of
accepting
what happened to you as something to
learn from
didn't that help redeem it a little bit
no yeah yeah it did
but it wasn't you know it's like there's
i was it wasn't fun
in it wasn't fun in a recreational sense
but it was
valuable it's like the process i some i
was
reading this this book where uh the
woman was talking about the process of
sort of
transformation that takes place in
people
who are who are trying to change uh
and the process of change she uses the
analogy of like
leather you know tanning a hide okay
and like you know at first it's just
really hard
it's not pliable at all it's like a you
know a big potato chip
it's like rawhide like what you would
give your dog to eat
but the process of tanning and
stretching and hanging it up i don't
know what happens to leather
but eventually it becomes nice and
supple but if you imagine yourself as
this hide
going through that process you're being
stretched and you're in the sun it's
not fun but you're becoming what you're
supposed to be becoming and
i know that's not what they yeah again
for a cowboy's crotch right that's not
what vacation
uh is vacation is traditionally like
it's a break from the norm it's a time
to relax it's a time to
when you live a uh yeah we do we have an
incredible
job we're living the dream but it's very
busy and there's constantly things that
we have to engage with trying to
disengage which is difficult for me
for me it was just that lesson of not
getting what you thought you wanted
but getting what you actually needed
i'm just saying when you ask that
question from from on a scale of one to
ten
i'm thinking the enjoyment factor yeah
yeah maybe the long-term value of it
it's a 10 versus if i had
gone down there and learned how to surf
and it was awesome it would have been a
one in the long term value but
once the injury happened seeing it
through the lens of
how can i grow here it helps redeemed it
i mean it redeemed it but at least she
wasn't enjoyable
okay yeah because every day i was like
man i wish i was surfing right now
and if i and thinking that even when i
do surf i'm gonna have to be on the
stand-up paddleboard i already know how
to do that
that's no fun you know what i'm saying
that that's how i was thinking about
ironically that's when it should be fun
because that's what you said earlier
right that when you know how to
well if it makes you feel any better i
offer also suffered an injury
oh good yeah i really did um
i you know i i tried to psych myself up
to low expectations
i was like set yourself up yeah for the
same reason because
you know i always have an idea of what
what the perfect anything
is you know and so there's this standard
that i'm constantly trying to meet
um and bring my family along to meet
that same standard
so i was just telling myself
you know severely complicates it when
other people you're expecting other
people
definitely you know what this is very
limited we can't go out
we can't make a lot of plans because
we're either going to be at home we're
going to order takeout we're going to go
to the beach
and i'm and i'm not going to put any
timetable or
we're not going to make any big plans
that require being anywhere at a certain
time or anything like that
and it was the the most laid back
vacation i've ever been up for that
reason
i didn't even make the kids get up at a
certain time oh we got to get on the
beach
we got to get a parking space so we're
going to be so far away i'm going to
have to
tote everything for everybody i'm gonna
have to make two trips three trips and
all this stuff i get worked up about uh
you know it wasn't an issue
you know there was there was parking
there was yeah so it was
definitely the most laid back vacation i
think and
having those lower expectations
really helped bring me to what i think i
said a seven
but i did have an injury i mean the one
you know i was like i'm gonna
i'm gonna eat all the foods i wanna eat
i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna bring my my ben and jerry's
like christy got this ben and jerry's
stash
man even before we got to the beach like
we brought a cooler to make sure we had
it
so like we're watching of course we're
watching some survivor
one once the nails start the needles
don't stop right
like still season
we're just watching it because i told
you you should have started
earlier and watched them all but no
there's other shows you're the
mclaughlin and i'm going to tell you
about
it you do it differently and i'm like
tonight's the night
i'm pulling out the ben and jerry's and
um i hurt myself eating ice cream
[Laughter]
uh i mean i'm talking i'm talking blood
oh did you bite your freaking lip no i
didn't get so excited that i started
biting my tongue and my
my cheek and my lip and all the stuff
that i that i do
i didn't do any of that i ate the whole
ice cream and man it was like
it was so good incredible flavor
christmas was like
uh tonight dough do you only get tonight
dough well
the number one on our peanut butter
world
you got to get that at target only yeah
i can't find it
um so i'm enjoying it chrissy's like how
much of that
because i had the pint how much of that
are you eating and i like showed it to
you and it was half gone i was like i'm
stopping right here halfway but this is
my pint
there's another pint of the same stuff
in there that y'all can share and
there's some stuff that i don't like
that y'all can have but this is my pint
and i'm eating out of it
one pint for the week um that's not
going that hard i also ate out of some
of theirs
when you because you when you thought
about like i'm gonna eat whatever i want
i mean
for me that would be well half a pint a
night
yeah i i didn't i mean i was eating lots
of pizza lots of mexican food lots of
i mean i i gained three pounds
interesting like i actually did yeah i
weighed
um because i'm pretty consistent in my
weight but anyway
so i'm eating the ice cream i'm enjoying
it and when it's
when it's done my mouth which was very
cold
all of a sudden i realized like my lip
is hurting
and then i i look down and
there's like some blood on my freaking
bend in jail
well that's definitely yours i hope it
is don't share that with anybody
yeah the bloody ben and jerry's is dads
and i'm
i'm putting the last taking the last
bite out of my mouth
and i'm realizing i mean with a knife
i've been eating with a knife this whole
time i have
i think this is worse i cut my lip
with a spoon the freaking i was like
i've cut my mouth with this spoon only
like meals
right here on the side on the side of my
mouth
i had cut gather round one dollar to see
the man who can cut himself with a spoon
not only once step right up two places
cause how
well it's a sharp spot i was like yeah
it was a sharp that's the edge of the
spoon was sharp
christy was like oh yeah sometimes you
know spoon goes
goes down in the garbage disposal it's
sharp and then again
and like it all it'll like whack the
edge a little bit and i think that's
what happened
so when i would pull the spoon out of my
mouth it would slice the edge of my
like where my lips come together on the
left side of my cheek why are you
putting it so
far to the side i'm just you know i'm
getting every last bit of ice cream off
and i thought a hundred people could eat
with a spoon and you would be the one
that would cut yourself with two slices
two and it and it wasn't just bleeding a
little bit brother
it was bleeding the mouth has a lot of
capillaries i mean i had to run in there
i mean i was like man am i gonna faint
i'm not gonna faint i'm not gonna faint
i just grabbed a paper towel i rolled it
up like a cigar
and i put it in the edge of my mouth
like a like gauze
and then we finished the driver and then
we finished survivor and then whenever
we had to pause it for dad to
save himself from the killer spoon yeah
so
i mean you can probably would have had
eight if you could still
serve with that bloody mouth
a lot more adventures to share but first
let's sell some merch um i'm actually
not wearing the shirt
that uh i want to bring your attention
to
i don't even know if the shirt that i'm
wearing is still available
cotton candy randy maybe it is that's
why you got to go to mythical.com but
the shirt that i want to tell you about
that you may have seen me wear elsewhere
is
the beans shirt um it just says beans on
it
it's my favorite shirt established what
does it say
is it says establish in 1984. beans were
made in 1984 for the first time so
they're it's been great
mythical it's just beans and i think
it's just mythical
1984. okay yeah it's a cool shirt uh
yeah it's just gray with blue lettering
you know beans i like it i like a good
gray shirt
um lots of things besides shirts most of
my shirt if i'm going to go to a t-shirt
it's going to be a great one a lot of
guys i mean
i got so many gray things it's just
great
but if you have a gray shirt you can't
be the guy that wears gray shorts
because then you just look like
you're in a uniform i don't like gray
shorts no i've thought about this
because i love gray things
and i have grey shoes and i have gray
yeah hats you gotta have
gray shirts but i don't have gray shorts
maybe i should just switch it up go
grace shorts black shirt
nope mythical.com
get your bean shirt well okay so i said
four but i want to
i want to talk about some of the i want
to talk about what i
think was the highlight for me because
there was some good things happened
right
um my mouth got better and this the next
morning
when i woke up my mouth was very quickly
because of all the blood flow
it's why it bleeds why and that's why it
heals but let me tell you i
i inspected all them spoons before i
went back in to throw those sharp spoons
out or just put them down the garbage
disposal
well we washed it and i put i put it
back in i didn't feel i didn't feel good
about throwing put a warning on it
um i feel bad about that now so another
of my expectations
and maybe this sends it up beyond a four
now that i think about it because i was
kind of just thinking about me
selfishly um again i had an expectation
that the kids would learn how to surf
right shepard
never has surfed he's been on the paddle
board with me
but he's never surfed by himself and
locke had been
a couple weeks before the vacation and
had served
in near san diego and had a good time
um but the first couple of times we just
went out with
uh me and lock and lock's friend who's
who's staying with us and
chore boy yeah the one who just he
carries everything for us
he doesn't and um
it was really cool because first of all
lock is better than me at regular
surfing already
because you're not saying much just a
bit which
by that i mean his ability to pop up
when he catches a wave and actually surf
it in
i'm not saying he's like turning and
like yeah all that but
he just you know he's an athletic kid
and just immediately just got it and
popped up and was just riding these
waves in
and was having an incredible time and
was like motivated to
go out with me in the morning and oh
that's cool
so and now it's something that we could
do together which he's like when are we
going again like now that we're back up
back at home so that was super cool to
see him kind of catch
something like that and then uh
we had one we had one wetsuit
that was a little bit too big for
shepard and a little bit too small
for for lock's friend and so they would
they would use this
they would share it so he couldn't go at
the same time and shepard speaking of
sleeping late
shepard the boy would sleep to one
o'clock
oh wow yeah my my older kids can do that
and uh so lando's at 10 he still
he will not do that it will change soon
um so i mean because this this has been
like the last year or so for shepard
as he's like you know becoming you know
he's about to turn 12.
so the uh
but i was like okay shiver we're gonna
go surfing now i hurt my back on day two
still had not taken shepard surfing but
the next day
i was like okay well i can't surf but i
can take you out there so me and shepard
got up we go out there
and you know i got my wetsuit on and i'm
like i'm just gonna
i mean in the water i'm gonna do the
things that i've seen
other like surf instructors do which is
like what you said
all right we're gonna get on shore we're
gonna put the board on the beach
i'm gonna show him how to pop up right
okay he gets he gets that pretty quickly
gonna go out there you know they can't
really paddle yet enough to kind of get
themselves in a wave so you push them
into a wave
yeah so i go out there and literally
like the second wave that he tried
i push him into the wave he stands up
rides it all the way into the sand yeah
he's so light
and he he's athletic and he's and he's
fearless yeah he's not scared of
anything but being that light helps a
lot
oh yeah if i could just start it at that
age man oh just start now
learn how to do things are you all you
12 year olds listening
no no i i'm saying
the the any sport where your
distance from said thing that you're
supposed to like be
on like surfboards skis
snowboard golf your distance from the
thing green you're on the green
well no your distance from the ball it's
like the taller you get
trust me i'm tall the harder it's going
to get you want to start
early start short and stay short
you know start short stay short smoke
cigarettes so you
won't grow oh gosh um
so the but that was a proud dad moment
to like see him and then to be like
oh he's he he wants more he's he's back
out he's got this huge smile on his face
pushing in some more waves and i said
all right shepard you're on your own man
i'm not going to push you now
i'm going to go in i'm going to sit on
the beach and i'm going to watch you
i'll go into the beach maybe take a nap
and uh i'm watching him and he just
catches a wave by himself and then he
goes back out
and like he was you know when you're
learning how to surf you kind of start
in the white water
area yeah but the next time he just goes
out he just paddles past that and
paddles all the way out with all the
other surfers
and i'm like okay i don't know how this
is going to go
he didn't catch any waves while he was
out there but boy he tried for like half
an hour
wow and uh it's nice when they get
motivated self-motivated yeah and that's
the thing is that you know he likes to
play video games he's really
motivated to do that um but
he hasn't he's done a lot of different
things but he hasn't like
been like oh this isn't the thing that
i'm gonna do and i'm super
self-motivated to do it so it was really
cool to see him do it
and again it was like one of those
things like this is really cool like i
just watched him learn how to surf and
now he's motivated to do it and the rest
of the week he went out with us and
um you know ended up catching more waves
so while i
selfishly wanted to be surfing and
learning to surf myself
it was cool to see both of the kids kind
of take to it
and now it's something that we can do
together which
you know i was sitting out there on the
beach and i was like
i'm a dad and i just did that
it doesn't sound like you did much yeah
you did enough there's not
you don't unless a thing you don't
really have to do much yeah that's
that's the it's actually
teaching a kid to surf versus teaching a
kid how to ride a bike
oh ride a bike oh that'll make you want
to kill your kid
surfing totally different ball game
super easy
well it depends i mean i took lando out
i mean he he's he's a he's more cautious
he's i'm not going to say timid i'll
just say cautious
and i said hey we're going to ride this
surfboard like a boogie board
that's going to we're going to get you
on this thing get you going
and um you know the first one
i i always do this i got a little
too aggressive too aggressive yeah and i
went out too far and then the wave was a
little too big and i like
i said stay you're at the right place on
the board
maybe you need to come back a little bit
further you know then you don't want the
nose to dive in
and i i pushed him on that wave right
when we got out there and he just like
it was chaos and then he comes up of
course this
i grabbed the board so the board doesn't
hit him or something like that and i'm
like all right let's go back out
and he's immediately going in but i have
the board
and the board is tethered to it it's
tethered to his ankle
right that's how you catch him and um
low dad moment for me was
continuing to go out i mean like drag it
drag his butt out there
i was like hold up we'll do this
differently it was my fault
like well i i i screwed up
you know i i got over aggressive and
then my response was always
where i really screwed up i was like i
was like no we're going
you're not giving up you're not giving
up and of course he couldn't go
i wasn't dragging him out i stayed in
place and he realized
that he couldn't go in i was like you're
not giving up we're gonna do this
together
and he was upset and he won and we went
back in
and he went and like basically told
christy
how big of an [ __ ] i was
and it was you know what totally true um
but it was just i wanted it for him so
badly right that like i did
i was doing it for me not for him and it
especially when it didn't work out
then it was i wasn't being sensitive at
all and i feel horrible about it
and so i took a few minutes to process
that and i was like hey
and i apologize i look in the eye and
i'm like i didn't do that right
i i want i want you to try again
but the i know you like things to be
explained to you so you can
you can know what to expect and i didn't
do that and it
so i was like basically let's have a
do-over
and you know what after a few minutes
he was like let's oh the same day let's
try it
so yeah like 20 minutes later we went
back out and i
and i i did it the right way
and um by the end of it he was like
maybe i'll try to get up on my knees or
something but it but it was a positive
experience and it was better than being
on a boogie board because you go so much
further when you're
as light as he is um
i think that i get i had forgotten
about that until i just told you because
that was that was kind of the low point
of vacation because the low point that i
remembered was the point where
i got angry that i wasn't another i
wasn't referring to that so i guess
there were two of them
uh we pack everything up from the beach
and like i had to take the boards back
up and
you know i'm in charge of the biggest
stuff because i we gotta go up this long
steps up the side of this cliff to get
back to the car
and the goal is still everybody pull
your weight
so that we only have to make one trip
right but i got and i got the big stuff
and so we get back up there we get
everything loaded in everybody's
everybody's pulling their weight
everything's going good
somebody left something we get back home
and i take my sunglasses off at the
house and i'm reaching for my
regular glasses and
i'm like where are my glasses
and i'm saying this to christy in the
pacific ocean
i'm like where are my glasses she's
looking at me like why are you asking
me where your glasses are and i'm like
my glasses i had a speaker
i took the speaker had a case because i
didn't have glass a glasses case
i took this speaker out and because we
were playing the speaker on the beach
and i put my glasses in that case
and then you guys packed everything up
it's their fault and so that i could get
it's not your fault
the big stuff back up there so
did anybody see my glasses
it's it's like why are you asking me
well because you
you guys are the ones who packed
everything up right and because we're
we're back at the house now we you know
we've driven them i don't know 10
minutes back or whatever
and so i'm mad
i'm very mad i'm like dizzy i mean
i need my glasses to see i have contacts
i have enough contacts to last the rest
of the week
i could just be no glasses man but but
you need the glasses who's linking
without glasses
it's like i i bought a second pair of my
glasses
well there you go identical to my
current pair
so that if something happened to them i
would have them to like
to be linked yeah i'm the guy i'm the
one with the glasses
well don't be so attached to it i mean
i'm getting older about the second well
right
that i mean i'm the girl i'm the one
with the gray hair in glass you're
currently the one with glasses
uh the only one with glasses but those
glasses my backup glasses were stolen
two years ago from my car my own
freaking driveway oh man
screw you person who did that the
prescription you can't use them anyway
yeah jackass and i never got them
replaced because they're expensive they
steal anything else
uh some sunglasses yeah christie's those
are prescriptions
not my sunglasses so i'm mad i'm like
i've they've got to be on the beach so i
go back
i drive back and i'm i'm just so mad
i'm like this is not this is not
vacation
and then i'm i have to find a place to
park but did anybody say
something like oh yeah i i
did not grab that they were like he was
like here's the speaker the speakers in
the case
they put the speaker back in the case
and the glasses were not
so i was like that you know
they didn't care about my stuff when
they were packing it up
it's like i i trust my family to care
about everybody's stuff when they're
packing it up
not just wrong yeah you can't trust your
family i have to find a place to park
i'm i'm putting on a mask i'm i'm
running down all these steps trying not
to break my neck
i get down there and the tide comes in
so far
all the way to the cliffs all the way to
the cliffs if you leave anything on the
beach yeah it's gone
well or almost
i get down there and i run back to the
spot
and i'm like i'm exasperated because the
ties
literally the tide is coming over the
place where we had set up no one else
was there
and i'm like i'm looking around and i
look
to the right like go look into the ocean
you're not gonna believe this my glasses
were
floating away in the ocean you're joking
yeah i'm joking my glasses weren't there
at all oh i was so mad
they had already been taken but i had
this vision the ocean had taken them i
had a vision
that my glasses that that's what was
going to happen i was going to get there
just in time
even though it so much time at all your
glasses float
glasses don't float well some do the
flow in the ocean they don't float i
think they're even more buoyant in the
ocean i don't
one time i forgot i had on sunglasses
and i went back into the
ocean because i was hot and i dipped my
head totally in the water and when i
came up
it was a lot brighter and i realized
that i had just lost my sunglasses right
there yeah
one second ago you'll never find them
and i re and i just i
instinctively reached down gone forever
oh yeah those are my
green sunglasses that that people post
on twitter when i look like i'm
like smiling real big like i'm the sun
yeah and i'm wearing those glasses i
probably get a replacement for this
glasses two little inner tubes that go
around the glasses right
there two little donut inner tubes we
should sell those
like wings like yeah they go right on
the edge swimming wings
and then they hook the cords which go
behind your head and you're just like
not even that a dad golfer you don't
even have to do that yeah because
they'll float you let them go
but you know what they do make a thing
that is a floaty
football size football shaped thing for
your keys
that you could attach to glasses too
like boat keys
boat keys so i asked the people you know
you hate having to ask the people on the
beach hey did you happen to see
some glasses uh
yeah no they didn't yeah i make this
walk of shame back
up up the stairs i sit in the car
and i'm like i don't want to drive home
i'm just i'm so mad at that because they
don't care i can't even see my way home
i have my sunglasses on
their prescription
and then i was like dang it i remember
taking those glasses and putting them in
the case
and then i was like but i think they
were my sunglasses
and i think my regular glasses
are in my sunglasses case right
here in the console of the car and i
opened it up took out how they were
took out my sunglasses case and they
just
laughed in my face i mean it i've never
seen glasses
laugh at a person but i felt it it's
like
well that's a beautiful moment when you
find the thing that you thought that you
lost
i mean you feel stupid for having i was
so
tripped down well i was so convinced
that it was my family
who collectively did this
so i came home and i told them the same
story i told you except i
i stopped at the part where i got him
out of the ocean yeah
yeah i'm about to say man you know
they there's no reason they have to know
what happened no i told him the truth i
mean
see that's the thing it's not about
being perfect it's about being penitent
and i'm glad that lando responded to
that and i mean
christy was like now you need to tell
the whole story if you're going to tell
that story
yeah that always happens when i lose
something
and i've actually learned at this point
to
um not
fi to not just immediately try to find a
family member
that's one of the great things about
having family is that you've got
that many more people to blame things on
yeah um
but it just it's always a losing game
you know
it's always a losing game it's not fun
even if it is their fault to blame stuff
on people
and what is that you lose stuff it's
almost always your own fault
that christy has is i've been listening
i've been looking i've been retracing my
steps i've been thinking so hard i've
been looking for the thing and it's like
uh and then she's like here it is you
know what is that superpower
it's just like and then that trains you
to not
look because if she can magically find
it well
i'm not going to waste time looking for
something that you can magically find
and i tell her that she's like this
magical it doesn't work that way the
magic only works
if you've exasperated yourself to the
point
of exhaustion and frustration
it helps if you don't blame anybody
because the magic doesn't work if you
blame
if i blame christie her magic doesn't
work and if i don't look her magic
doesn't work but if i
if i put in the effort and then i get
exasperated i go to her
on hand oh baby i need you baby i can't
i can't find my
i can't find my glasses that's what it
takes uh
i know i put them in the wrong place but
can you work your magic
then it'll work what you want you want
to enlist the help of your family
without blaming them we're talking about
bounty that's the only way my family's
gonna get involved my kids
you can have my bloody ice cream if you
find my glasses
uh iron is that a higher iron the other
the other thing that that
happened to me speaking of watching
television as you watch survivor
um still love it now i'm sure you suffer
from
a similar thing uh no uh don't be sure
a lot of people struggle
with the whole aspect of not
doing right so even while on vacation
i'm still thinking about accomplishing
something
it might be oh you're going to learn how
to surf properly
um and i think that you know going back
to like
the enneagram one in the enneagram three
there's a lot of similarities in the way
that we approach things
you might want to make sure your
vacation
goes perfectly and i might want to
unlock and achieve accomplish something
on my vacation but they
they manifest themselves in pretty
similar ways a lot of times so for me
and this is a common workaholic problem
i feel it's very difficult for me to
enjoy a vacation because i feel
worthless if i look at a day on vacation
and i'm like you didn't do anything
like you didn't learn how to do anything
you didn't like achieve something like
because even doing something like having
a good time is achieving something
if you just sort of laid there you kind
of got up late
and then you watched a lot of television
and then dinner rolled around
and like my wife is really good at just
sort of embracing that
and enjoying that and being able to just
be
in that being something that is fun and
enjoyable
whereas i just developed this sense of
worthlessness
uh and like i have no value because
again my tendency is to attach my value
to my accomplishments something that i'm
unraveling like a giant
knot yeah since i've been in therapy
i've had that problem a lot
with just with covid in terms of work
because we're
we're hamstrung in a lot of ways in
terms of what we can do and like
what we're working on that leads to
stuff and that's another thing that
happens to me when i go on vacation not
only am i thinking well you're going to
learn to surf
but i also think that like oh you're
also going to have this thought
about some project that we're working on
you're going to have a breakthrough
you're going to come up with a new idea
you're going to write a song like
i had this secret hope
and because of my personality many times
that's what vacation
is filled with there's like oh i wrote
two songs or you know it's
i came up with an idea i did this little
write-up
and i do that in in part because
that's where i get my self-worth right
so i mean it's it's it's good if you're
trying to be an entertainer but it's
also bad
i i'll veg out over here you you keep
going with that
and uh but it's bad for your own mental
health so but one of the things that i
found myself doing especially after i
got hurt is
you know i talked a lot about how jesse
and i had watched
uh married at first sight talked about
that a few
podcasts ago and it turned a lot of
people on to that and it's i
mean yeah you're welcome i know i don't
know i don't know and uh
well you're definitely not gonna know
about this so the th now
my wife and i well let me say my wife
watches a lot of trashy reality tv and
she has wrote me into it
and i fall for a hook line and sinker
even if i am trying to resist it
and the thing that we ended up getting
into which this is even more popular
than meredith first sight
is we started watching 90 day fiance
before the 90 days and i guess this is
the most recent
season now you've seen this guy ed
um you may not know that he is ed but if
i showed you
a picture of ed you'd be like oh that's
the guy from all the memes
over the past couple of months okay and
i i can barely say what 90 day fiance is
90 day fiance
is a show about people who are
there's one person who's in the u.s and
then one person who is in a foreign
country
and they are getting married in order
for the person to get a green card
oh this is the thing that the only
lincoln was watching pewdiepie watch one
of these
yeah yeah it's super popular so i
watched it with him that's the only way
i've seen the show
and felix watched it i told you this he
watched the episode
segments out of order yeah and he cared
so
little that he just he didn't even he
was like oh i'm watching these out of
what the story was out of order
like they got him yeah yeah they it was
but which i found hilarious
there's like five different versions of
the show because there's 90 day fiance
but then there's
90 day fiance before the 90 days and
then there's so what's the before
so before the 90 days is a different
show so this is them
meeting the people who they
might have then gotten engaged to and
then the 90-day fiance is late
after they've gotten engaged and isn't
going to work out so i don't even know
how old this is but it's the same people
that i've seen in the memes
so it's relatively recent so they shot
they
documented they documented them for the
first time and dating basically yeah
before they
got engaged yeah but they didn't air any
of that so they had a spin-off show
because they had so much footage
that was like a prequel it's absolutely
incredible now you have to be a certain
kind of personality but based on the
popularity of this show and what i see
on the internet
there's a lot of people who fit this
personality type that will get drawn
into this kind of thing
because you it's the same reason i
watched the bachelor or anything like
that you just
can't believe that people are
capable of this type of behavior and you
just keep watching it and i know that
there's some sort of thing going on
that's just like
i feel like by watching these people be
themselves
it makes me almost feel it makes me feel
separated and
a little bit sane it's like i would
never do that so it makes you feel good
because you're kind of
separating yourself from the actions of
these people as opposed to it making you
angry and frustrated that they're
like making dumb decisions uh it makes
me angry and frustrated but i'm
more blown away okay i'm i'm gonna
if you're gonna watch 90 day fiance
before the 90 days spoiler i'm gonna
spoil something so just
spoiler alert um
but the thing that okay so first of all
there's ed and there's rose right
and ed is this like 55 year old dude
from san diego
who has a very let's i'll just say he is
his look is very distinct and that's why
he's kind of become popular in these
memes and
okay and then rose is like a 20
something year old like 23 years old
from the philippines
their relationship is bonkers
but very entertaining are you looking
him up ed
and rose yeah and rosemary
yeah rosemarie so you know that guy oh
yeah yeah
yeah he's in he's in everything right
and he's like there's a famous scene
where he like sits down next to her at
the pool and he's like
you're my he's like you're my vision or
so i can't remember what it is it's just
a bunch of memes because because the
things that he says and then the
way that she talks to him back to him is
just
phenomenal now like she's younger than
his she's younger than his daughter
and so he's he's a large man
yeah with slick-backed hair and like
he's not
never clean-shaven and his
yeah he's uh his head just kind of goes
into his shoulders right and i think
that's why
you know he's got that very distinct
physicality that people have
uh you know people have locked into now
okay
now let me tell you about this other guy
okay oh another guy
this is the thing that kept me they and
the freaking tlc producers they're
so good because
let me just say each one of these
episodes is an hour and 40 minutes long
what i think that's right this is the
rejected
i'm watching the prequel footage i'm
watching this on i think tlc.com i don't
know jesse's doing it there's this on
the apple tv
i'm sitting through there's commercials
i'm watching commercials like there's
six commercials in a commercial brand
you watch commercials
there's no way you can't if you want to
i guess there's maybe unless you want to
buy the season on amazon i don't know
how
i'm just i'm just trying to give you a
picture of just how much i had succumbed
to reality tv i'm watching commercials
again
i'm buying things that i'm seeing you
know a swiffer no you didn't no i didn't
but you thought about it
but it's gone in my brain i'll tell you
that i'm gonna buy it at some point
somebody just heard you say it and and
the ads are increase the chances
advertising works if it doesn't then me
and you are gonna be probable
so let me just so there was one day
where we watched i don't know how many
episodes back to back
but i guaran damn to you it was seven
hours of this show
i've never watched this much television
in one sitting
and i was taking breaks and like eating
but i kept coming
freaking back and we and we didn't even
pause it we would go downstairs and do
something it would just be keep rolling
and because you don't really have to
follow that closely
but the story that i could not
i could not escape from can i ask you
something you can ask me anything you
want at this
at the seven and hour one i hate it i
hated myself at minute seven
you don't understand i hated myself the
whole time
did you know you were like oh this is
happening i'm not doing this i actually
thought to myself and i told jesse this
like five hours in i was like
this is and i'm not i'm i'm not making
light of this
i was like this is what it feels like to
be addicted to drugs
oh gosh because i was like you can
imagine
that like you keep going back to this
thing and you know that it's not good
for you and you don't even
really like it but you can't stop i was
like i have a whole lot of empathy
for people who are addicted to drugs
right now
i'm addicted to tlc
hold on and i'm about to tell you why
is it because of you wanted to find out
what happens
yes okay okay
well i mean but they got engaged that's
what happened
before the 90 days dude you don't
i'm about to blow your mind you know
what's gonna happen you don't
you don't you don't especially in one
particular case right
so there's all kinds of things like
there's one woman who
is basically being catfished by this
dude and you know as the viewer that
she's being catfished
you know that this dude's not real but
she's so convinced that and you can't
stop watching someone
in their delusion and it's kind of sad
because i know that the producers
and everyone knows that this person is
in a delusion and you should
it's like you remember the famous
there's a fan and teller there's a
famous photograph from an ethical
standpoint there's
there's multiple photographs of like um
really difficult things to see like a
child who's starving or somebody who's
been
injured or and there's a person who
takes the photograph and there's like
this journalistic
ethic which is i don't intervene i just
observe
and then people find out oh you took
this picture but you didn't help this
kid or whatever
uh there's a certain aspect to it where
you're like
you kind of want to just be like you
know hey i got this isn't real
but you know that the producers
understand letting them
live out their delusion is this in
intensely entertaining thing that you
can't
stop watching now one particular
delusion
that is i think the key reason i kept
going back there's a dude
named i know we're going a little bit
long but i've got to tell you this
you know what there is no perfect length
right there's nothing to you don't need
to you know what
maybe you don't need to tell the story
because you feel like you need to
achieve
the end of the story no no no no no no
you have got to hear this
so there's a guy named david who is from
las vegas
okay he's in his 50s i believe maybe
yeah let's just say that he might be 60
i don't know
this guy uh
goes to these dating services
online dating services where it's a it's
a site
where these russian women and i think
maybe in this case it was a ukrainian
woman
um
they're on the site and you see a
picture of them and you can begin
chatting with them
not video chat text chat showcase only
okay and and you know that
do they basically want to you know come
to america well let's get
hold your horses okay stay in stay in
the ukraine for a second
so you chat text chat with this person
who by the way does not speak english
and so everything that you're saying is
being translated into
ukrainian i guess and vice versa so
you're not even
there's a language barrier but it's sort
of overcome by this text tool yeah
and you pay by the minute
this guy first of all it comes he comes
to light that again spoiler it comes to
light that he's been chatting
up lots of women over the years and that
this is basically
the extent of his adult relationships at
least for
the past 10 15 years oh and
this one woman lana is her name now
lana's not making any of the money that
you that he's paying for the phone call
she gets paid yeah she is oh she gets
paid to talk to him
well she she gets paid by the site
oh how why would she do it if she's not
getting paid
to find a date no no no no no this is
her job
her job is to go on this site and to
talk to multitudes
of men who want to chat with this pretty
blonde
russian lady oh oh okay so it's like
but it's not just it doesn't have to be
it's like a
what was that it's like the sex line
yeah but you're but you're text chatting
but it's no but it's not just about the
sex
let me just let me just say a couple of
things so as i'm watching i thought it
was a i thought it was just a dating
line
but it's not it's a service okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's
it you're he's paying half a million
dollars
oh gosh okay over the course of the
years okay to chat with these women
and for seven years he's been chatting
now first of all he's never seen
any he's just seen the picture and then
chatted
so everyone watching knows
that this woman is almost assuredly not
the person that he is talking to right
it's just some dude named boris
who who's talking back to him right
could be a.i but
he is convinced that they are in a
relationship
he considers her his girlfriend because
that's
what she does on the uh she
acts as if she's in a relationship with
him right so for
seven years this goes on now over the
course of the seven years
and this is all before you before we're
seeing it
he has been too i don't know if again i
know
you can't ukraine is not russia i don't
know which one he went to
but he i think maybe he went to the
ukraine i'll just say that
three times to meet her and every single
time he has met
her she's come up with an excuse now let
me explain
he only communicates with her through
the service
even when he's going to meet her in the
ukraine
and so like he'll be like why can't i
just get your number and she and she
gets mad
and she's like only through the chat
only through the thing
so he's paying her to arrange a meeting
with her and every time he goes over
there paying
on his own time she's not there because
an excuse comes up my brother died or
what
she's got all kinds of excuses and we
know the producers know the audience
knows
this guy is in the depths of a delusion
it's sad
but you're just like how far is he going
to go because
when we're watching the show he's
talking to her and he's like i'm going
back
i'm going back over there and i'm going
to meet her and this time she's going to
be
at this train station order so you see
him go over there
this was the first time cameras followed
him up yeah but you see him
talk his friends like try to have
interventions with him like oh we're
gonna get a shot at you and your two
friends at this bar and you're talking
and it's like david
i you know i really think this is a scam
and he's like i don't believe it's a
scam
and he has a weird sort of robotic way
of approaching it where he's not going
to listen to reason right
so other people have tried to intervene
multiple people okay his friends
and even even a russian producer's case
a little bit a russian lady
who is was on the services that he met
at one time
is telling him that this is a scam and
he meets her when he goes over there
and she and she's since got married to
somebody else and she's out of the game
now but so
he goes back over there for a fourth
time of course she doesn't show up he
comes back home
and then you know a couple hours later
i'm still in the bed i'm still watching
this
he's going back again
yeah why are you doing i can't i don't
and i'm like i can't believe you're
watching
this well i'm also following like five
other couples at the same time
but i just this one in particular was
like i just
don't how is it possible that he's going
there for the fifth
time and then
he's like okay she's supposed to be here
at 11 o'clock he's still never talked to
her
through anything but the chat yeah and
this very distinct blonde woman
alert don't listen to what i'm about to
say if you want to enjoy this yourself
she's there what the woman from the
pictures
shows up and hugs him and
i'm just like having invested so much
time
into this and feeling so worthless it
was like another hit
it was like it was all of a sudden like
ah this was all worth it
what but she was an actress no
they just brought in so many things were
going through my mind i was like did the
tlc producers like find this woman from
the pictures and say hey will you act
like it was you this whole time yeah
let's make his day
it was her but she
when they interviewed her it was very
clear that she was continuing to carry
on
the i this she wants the money she wants
the gifts from him
and it seems that she wants
the ability to come to the u.s i think
at this point
where i stopped watching the show which
was the tell-all which was like during
kovid where they're all on video chat
oh wow so like after the after the 90
days
she didn't even show up for the for that
and he was like i haven't spoken to her
in six days i think the engage they got
engaged
they got engaged and i was just like
so she's also she's also
maybe an addict too like she whatever
he's giving to her
she's addicted to money man okay but it
was
i had to mellow this before it was a 90
day fiance episode
i guess but it was so
like i don't know what the moral of it
is i mean for me
it's tough i don't for me it's just like
i can't let this happen
unless i'm on vacation right i feel
worthless
i hate myself for doing this i don't
know why i'm so invested in finding out
if this woman's real
i don't know what's going to happen with
ed and rose i mean ed told rose that she
needed to shave her legs and that she
had bad breath
and it's like i really i don't like the
way that he told her that
but how she gonna respond and then like
oh
is what's her name gonna find out that
williams is
not a real dude that she's being
catfished like
you just you find yourself so invested
in this and i underst
but i think the moral of the story for
david though i think is
if you have a delusion just follow it to
the end of the yellow brick road
because you're probably right it may
come true you're probably right
now listen i'm not shutting this down
because i got
questions i'm i got i'm i'm flooded you
should just i'm flooded with
memories associated with this so hold on
you've been i don't even know
i training woman i don't care if this
goes you know what
it's maybe a part two or you know
let's just blow it open every time you
get so invested in a freaking
trash show it becomes an episode i think
i need my own podcast where i just talk
about reality tv
can we do that why am i not invited i
mean somebody's gotta
somebody's gotta tell you you have a
problem and that you just can't
give in to this see you you need to take
a breath
no but if i could make money off of it
then i start to feel like i'm worth
something
like if i could take my addiction to tlc
and other things like it
and turn it into a paying project then
i'll say oh this
okay that's good you can this makes
sense it validates your addiction it's
spending seven hours
i mean this is like i i this is like
those people who sit down and watch all
three of the lord of the rings
back to back to back which i i'm just
not that kind of person i cannot do that
no
but it's not because it's not lord of
the rings it's not yeah
it's a it's far from it it's real people
that have been
just marrying netted through producing
and editing
for your for you to feel sorry for them
or feel better about yourself or
all this psychology is it could be
troubling but it does remind me
um when we started producing commercial
kinks
so we made the pilot yeah with revelli
we worked with todd who brought us in
and produced that and like we had a
producer
um who worked on survivor actually uh
shoot well his name is on the tip of my
tongue
uh fernando yeah yeah yeah yeah fernando
was the one
who's what like we were we were we were
filming the pilot episode
in the in the mountains of asheville
north carolina and
with heavy hill the trash man yeah a
garbage collector
and then we had some down time and we
hadn't talked
talked about it ahead of time and then
all of a sudden fernando's like
i want to we want to set up some some uh
otf interviews otf on the fly interviews
it's like you know how on like reality
competition shows and stuff like that
they'll like
have confession cams or they'll be
talking to a producer and we hadn't
thought about this at all hadn't thought
about it at all
and he was like it may not be part of
the show but let's just do it
and and then we made a decision we were
he wanted us to do them individually and
we didn't feel good about that i
remember but we did it and i remember
he um he set up a shot of me
um standing in front of heavy hills
shed in his backyard where he had his
pet mule back there yeah i remember this
and um then you had a little down time
while he interviewed me and i remember
when he interviewed you i was like
watching i was like what's
i think he interviewed you first i was
like how's this going to go and here we
were
we'd like to be in control it was our
show
we were you know we were producers on
the show too
and executive producers executive
producers and we were producing the
commercial within the show so it's like
we had our hands in all of it yeah and
um
uh it felt a little weird being
interviewed by fernando who like
in in one sense worked for us but then
he was interviewing us
documenting the process of us making
these commercials so like
he would he would throw things at us and
we would talk about it and then they
and then that ended up being cut into
the episode um
but then we went to all of that was a
tangent by the way
oh you're getting but it was like well i
guess we we became
that was where i started to feel like we
were
actually putting it no we were in a
reality television show
you know commercial kings was a show
documenting us making a commercial but
we never thought of it that way
we thought of it as we're producing a
show that shows how we make the
commercials
but what fernando tried to achieve was
the level of detachment from what
the how we were going to be presented
and what we're processing in this
and and let our process and our point of
view
not become just editorial but becomes
something that happened on screen
and it's difficult when the people that
you're doing that with are really
self-aware
and also producing the show yeah meaning
us
pretty good at it it's separating so
it's like when he'd ask us a question
yeah half
half the time we were thinking what is
the best way to answer this question to
be entertaining but also connect the
dots so that in the edit room we can
tell the best story and we win that we
would be
way better at that now than we were in
2011. oh yeah we weren't good at it no
no but if we would have just let go and
trusted fernando and just
answered his questions which we would do
now which we would do now
but we understand how to be ourselves
yes a lot more than we did in the early
days
like right now yeah i you know there's
so many times i wish we could go back
and do commercial kings again
it and i think that was a part of it it
stuck in our crawl
that like we were doing these on-the-fly
interviews and that's the part of the
show i don't like watching it was
reduced i don't like watching those
interviews
in series though and this is what i was
originally getting to but it's
so it wasn't a tangent continuation of
my thought in series we worked with a
different production company we worked
with joke productions
yeah uh the company that
um that funded the show and sold it
and produced the pilot they basically
said we need to bring in somebody else
who
who does this day in and day out who can
do it
on a tighter budget yeah uh joke
productions
um was joke and biagio they're a married
couple
uh um and joke is her name she's like
for some reason she's like belgian or
something and
yeah and so joke doesn't mean funny haha
over there but it works well it
translates well i made all that up i
actually don't know
why they called her joke that's her name
was that right
yeah they didn't mean funny haha in
belgium i don't think so
i think it's just a name okay maybe i
wasn't joking sometimes i say things
just because they might be cool to say
and then i realized i'm accessing a
memory that i didn't know i had
oh well that's part of life i remember
the first episode we shot with them
was make me a pro wrestler
that was the name of the business we
were doing the commercial for we aired
them all out of order the heavy hill
pilot episode aired somewhere in the
middle the make me a pro wrestler
didn't turn out it wasn't it was a
dynamic commercial it had a lot of
action but it didn't have a hook and it
wasn't it didn't
come together but we learned how to be
wrestlers and you freaking with your
back and everything suplexed me and it
hurt my back
by the way yeah it did um but we tried
to get the guy who was
called the hobo right yeah his name he
was a
his wrestling persona was the hobo we
said we interviewed them all
and and we wanted to play brandon was
his name
yeah yeah and he i think he he's still
involved in wrestling at some point he
was
up until recently because uh our buddy
sievert who
who helped produce uh buddy sister the
second season of buddy
who was one of the writers on buddy
system showrunners
um his son had a connection to the world
of
sort of amateur pro wrestling and so we
kind of kept up and we actually
talked about this moment when we tried
to get the hobo
to change his persona to the baby and we
said
on camera we thought it would be
entertaining it would be an entertaining
beat
to mess with these people's personas to
make them more marketable
and so on camera it's like we knew okay
the big moment is when we tell
brandon to shave his head that he needs
to shave his head
and he wears really long hair and it was
his signature for the hobo
and wear a diaper and he's just going to
be a bald man with a diaper
and i felt horrible about this because
that goes
i mean in my mind that goes a step
beyond what they're doing on tlc
tlc is like i'm gonna let this person
flounder in their delusion and
and i'm going to i'm going to film it
for entertainment and all of our we were
trying to manipulate
all of our commercials that really took
off it was taking things that were
true and things that came out that we
worked out of the woodwork
to become all of those commercials um
you know like common liquidation that
epic and honest mobile home commercial
everything that he says is something
that he told us
and then we just scripted it out um but
then
joke and biagio started to try to teach
us
that it's not you know we didn't go with
this docky reality thing we went with
this
they made it more reality tv let's have
a
we need to have an entertaining beat in
act one you guys make it
make a great commercial that's act three
but if they don't
they gotta get hooked in act one and
then you gotta be some stakes and act
two this is a comedy
you gotta say some funny stuff and so
putting these people in these situations
where it's like they have to respond to
us telling a dude to shave his long hair
and his and his beard right yeah
everything
yeah because he he had hair like you do
now and a beard maybe he didn't
have a beard actually he had long hair
though yeah it was his hair because
in the moment when we were trying to get
him to shave it and he was getting
really close to
there i felt he was so horrible yeah
because it was like we were criticizing
his creative choice to be the hobo but
also i still feel like the baby is a
better persona
and i still i i feel that's honest
well i think he was hurt a little bit
that he was like the hobo
the thing that i've invested myself in
isn't good enough
and you're asking me to i've also
invested in my hair
i've grown up my hair and you want me to
shave it off to be a baby
and the reason why we know this is
because
they did on the fly interviews where we
weren't there where they asked
brandon and then that's when we found
out
that he was on the verge of tears
talking about how he talked to he went
home and he talked to his mom
yeah yeah yeah there's a lot of us just
looking like [ __ ] in this
in this podcast but you know what it's
the truth uh we were torn
but daniel who was our like i i think
his title was great
director he was a creator he came on as
a creative consultant but then he
basically became
a director yeah but that's a weird title
for
reality well it's important though so
it's a part of it
he was i remember daniel in the corner
sitting on the floor with his
knees up on his chest and literally with
his hands in his
hair yeah yeah just he was thinking
almost pulling his hair out
and he was on the verge of tears and he
was like we can't make this and then
he and we can't do this to this guy we
can't do
and we were like you're right and then
like joke
i mean i love joke i haven't you know
it's like
she was you know she's like she was
focused on the product and she had this
she had the counter points
it's like guys this is he's not he's
just shaving his head it's his decision
to do it it's not the end
of the world he can't wear a wig we're
not going to make him do it he's not
going permanently bald
this and all of this is is is uh is good
television
it's it was her point of view yeah yeah
yeah even even the fact that this is
stressing you out is why people would
want to watch it but we didn't document
that
no we didn't no the story that we're
telling now is what should have been
commercial kings yeah i think
we should have gone so much more raw and
sincere and there would have been a way
to do the show that didn't require this
overproduction too because
our on-the-fly interviews the reason why
you hate them and i hate them
if you go back and watch commercial
kings is because we got to the point
where we didn't have any we didn't do
them on location we said
we'll just do them when we get back to
los angeles when we're editing
and we'll know what we need to say to
connect the dots and you'll just go out
into like a nondescript neighborhood in
la with one cameraman and a producer
and then you'll connect the dots well
what happened was it was no longer an
interview it was
it was kind of scripted it was like
this is the idea that we need to
communicate yeah it was like we fed it
and now you guys need to put this
connected
you need to say that this guy
once he went home and told his mom and
he was on the verge of tears to shave
his head
you need to articulate why you
let him off the hook and said you don't
have to shave your head
all you got to do is wear the diaper
just be the baby for the commercial
then you can go back to being the hobo
and we would have to say that in the in
the uh on the fly interview that we that
we shot
months later and it just didn't have it
wasn't real
so to to wrap this up
so 10 years later being a producer
my point is being a producer on this
stuff is like
it it creates like an identity crisis
and it's
you have to i think they sleep fine
because it's a certain type of person
because let me get to what i'm getting
to you well i've been trying to
which is um ten years later
reality tv and people being portrayed
and watching themselves being portrayed
and understanding
even even if they're not particularly
self-aware of people who understand
television production
almost everyone understands the
manipulative nature
of reality tv now even the people who is
maybe even especially the people who are
on it right
yeah if you watch if you watch the um
after the person wins survivor and then
it's like the live show where they're
interviewing everybody
who competed that season yeah they'll
they'll talk openly about how
this is how i was portrayed in the edit
more specifically
with 90 day fiance for they're so genius
how they figured out
if you if you hadn't told me hey um so
we're going to do this show called 90
day fiance where
you know it's people getting green cards
whatever it's like okay i got it
and then we're going to find all these
ways to remix this and one of the ways
is we're going to film before the 90
days use that footage that we were
getting as they were establishing their
relationship okay that's the show
and then we're gonna do one where uh
there's a tell-all
where everyone is on a video chat
together and
everyone on the video chat has watched
all of the episodes of the entire season
so now you've got people
saying commenting on the other couples
and like butting in and giving advice
about what they should have done
okay there's another show i don't even
know what it's called
but it's when couples who have been on
90 day fiance in previous seasons
sit in their bedrooms and watch
a current season of 90 day fiance and
you're just
watching them watch 90 day fiance and
then there's a podcast
where a dude won't shut up about it no
but what i'm saying is is that
i feel like culturally we've gotten to a
point where
everyone understands what they're
getting themselves into
and they uh and they you know what i'm
saying it's like i'm not saying it's
not chatting for years with with
somebody being catfished i
i mean no no everyone can't understand
to the same no no i'm not saying that
it's not exploitive in some way
it is uh i'm just saying that
ten years have passed and a whole lot
has changed about the way people
think about the concept of reality tv in
the production
everybody knows that the things that
you're watching on keeping up with the
kardashians
are produced scenarios and moments and
we've gotten to a place where we don't
care anymore right if you're into that
kind of thing you don't care
well and but that's a different i don't
are you into that that's a different
type of reality
i mean i don't watch that early season
the duck dynasty is the last time i've
watched anything that has a point of
reference for
these are real people that then i can
tell that producers have given them a
scenario
hey you're going to do this you're going
to you knew it and you didn't really
care you're going to go hunting but you
got to have but you
but here's the problem that you're going
to encounter and you didn't care if they
were good at it if they were good at
making it happen
i think what ultimately what i'm saying
is regarding
i'm not kind of making a non-point in
one sense
because it's the point that stands is i
still
feel dirty watching it right
regardless of the i feel dirtier hearing
about 90 day fiance than like
the kardashians or the duck dynasties
thing where it's like the story lines
are
manufactured well yeah but at the same
time
these people they're in on it they
decided
i do want to do this i want to be in
this relationship
and this is a way for me to actually get
a green card or to be you know i mean
you have to have a legitimate in quotes
but when you have an addiction like i'm
first of all the guy was vindicated
that's the weird thing about it
kind of he was kind of dedicated but it
was but it seems like there was
and they didn't know that when they
started filming it he he needed
money to keep paying for the service
you know somebody i think that my wife
may be
at the door
oh they're dropping off a piece of
furniture
i need to go meet them at the door okay
oh i had a cramp that's in here so long
see what would be cool is if a piece of
furniture was delivered in the middle of
the podcast
and what are what are rhett link going
to do you know rhett's going to get up
he is he going to move the furniture
himself and hurt his back
well let's let him decide we know he's
got a bad back but let's deliver some
furniture and let's see what happens
maybe
maybe link will go out there and say
he's going to move it
or he'll probably just assume that
they're going to brett's going to ask
him to move it wherever because he has a
bad back
it's his fault if he decides to move the
furniture himself and
his back gets thrown out it better be
cameras there
there's three in here there's not one
out there
we're blowing our opportunity for a
reality tv moment
it's like here go go out there that's
where the action is
oh yeah it's a table it's an it's an
outdoor table
let me call my wife and ask her
this is this is reality right here
did the guy was he planning on
assembling or did you talk him into it
with a lacroix
i mean he's assembling it and he has
lacroix
good job should i leave my mask on
this whole setup looks good everything
boy the mask really changes the sound
doesn't it
yeah it's a bit muffled
uh so where does that leave us
we we're you know right there
well okay so you're back there's a guy
in there he's assembling a table
i'm out of breath did you move the table
i just moved did you
did you assemble anything this is why
this is the thing that i didn't
anticipate about covid is what's
happening with my beard right now
when i wear a mask i mean mask beard is
a real thing i
it's fine we should land this
reality tv ship if we want to keep it in
the context of the vacation
to me it was um
it made me it added to my feeling of
worthlessness
but it was the only thing that i could
really do because you can't really go
anywhere
my back was hurt you could watch other
shows you could read a book
i did i did that as well
apparently there's enough time to do
that and watch seven hours straight of
90 day fiance wow i mean when it was
over did you
did you tallied up and say we just
watched seven hours i think here's the
thing
me and you married dudes who run a
business
have a lot of stuff a lot of people a
lot of people do this on the rig
and we so we think the idea of sitting
down and watching but every time i mean
i talked to some of the folks that uh
some of the single folks that work for
us and they're like oh yeah i watched
i binged so and so over the weekend like
they watch a whole tele a whole season
of television over a weekend
and i've never done and they don't feel
worthless i'm i've ne
and i didn't even get to the bottom of
this one but what do you mean
there's more of it oh but i'm saying
that some people are like oh yeah i
watched the whole now that you're back
home are you
are you going back in no no no no no
okay okay that's a boundary
okay that's good i want to hear you say
it uh
i'm not well yeah jesse and i have a
window of time
sometimes during the week between like
nine
and ten o'clock where we'll watch
television together
uh i don't really watch it past like
maybe 10 30 is like the latest right
uh i i think anything goes in the pm can
easily turn into 5 a.m
anything goes in that window and i would
say that
i would technically allow 90 day fiance
to go in that window
because there's very little like i fall
asleep i'm not going to keep
i'm not going to watch it past 10 30
because i'll fall asleep stakes are
low for for for sleeping but i do think
that i'd rather watch something that is
a little bit more plot driven
than i say you know save that as a nice
treat it's just like i also had ice
cream
myself i ice cream twice spoon yeah i
didn't cut myself or anything
yeah but um i ice cream twice during the
week i don't eat ice cream yeah i don't
outside of our show i hit i
i i set a boundary so it's kind of like
i had some junk food i had some junk tv
i feel okay about myself i'm trying to
be okay with it
so don't make me feel bad about it i
felt horrible in the moment
but damn that story is he gonna this
does this woman exist
she does exist what this is freaking
nuts i still think it's nuts
they still exist and so where is it
right now
they're engaged i i think that the last
thing is that they were engaged but i
think that she's
she's backed out okay or she's m.i.a
right now
wow so that was our vacation so i
haven't took
30 minutes to talk about 90 day fiance i
could talk about it forever
it seems that you could i got other
things from a vacation i could talk
about
do you want to just you you know if you
could watch for seven hours
the um two life long friends
i just we're gonna make that time for a
long time we're gonna make that tagline
true that's what happens when you make a
tagline
you want we got anywhere to be you
fulfill it there are there's
there's other meetings there's i think
there's one that's starting
uh maybe even now oh snap well you got
to give your recommendation
wreck baby wreck baby one two three four
so okay uh i'm gonna recommend something
that
uh incidentally you're the one who took
it on vacation and i only knew about it
because
um shepherd was like
i think shepard went to your house or so
i can't remember what it was but shepard
comes back talking about how you were
really excited about something
uh-huh and he's like link's really
excited about this
he's buying bidets yeah and i'm like
buying bidets and he was like yeah like
a portable bidet
and i was like oh portable but i think
it came in the mail when you were
when he was there that is genius yep
i am so i hear about you getting this
thing and then i'm like
genius you know i go on vacation and i'm
sitting there with a regular american
toilet
i feel like a barbarian you know just
wiping my butt with paper
doing who knows what to my rectum long
term you might as well be wrapping your
cheeks around a
tree yeah just like just still growing
taking a sapling and just squatting up
and down yeah
a rough bark sapling a pine tree
and uh i was like man i got to get me
one of these and then i go on amazon you
like 10 bucks you can get a little
squeezy thing
oh i paid more for mine well you i mean
mine did the job i tested it yesterday
oh
my i got mine in my freaking backpack
now because i don't have anything
here mine accordions shut and goes into
it goes
oh mine goes in a bag but it doesn't
accordion mine accordions out and it
makes it where you can really
play music at the same time plays music
all i know is
i recommend this now first of all we
recommend bidets in general because we
have
been talking about that and you know
what i'm beginning to notice
that the idea of a bidet is catching on
in america
it is i saw because of us i saw it's a
cultural
movement and we just have a new party
it's a moment we're part of a movement
there was an instagram ad and it was
just a little kid talking about how
ridiculous it was to wipe your butt with
toilet paper and it was like what's the
ad for a bidet okay
i saw an ad on instagram for it for
tushy
yeah dude it's a bidet here's the thing
here's what you're you're
you people are resisting this you're
gonna it's happening
your booty is gonna be getting sprinkled
really soon
it will happen this is everybody because
it's better
loves to gush about it no pun intended
wow that's good i was i was
on instagram i saw an ad for
tushy which was a
it's an add-on to your toilet that's a
bidet this should be a sponsor
and um they're not a sponsor but they
should be a sponsor let's make that
happen
and i was i was prepping for my vacation
i see this ad and i say you know what
all you got to do is take the lid off
the toilet put it down put the lid back
on and then hook it up to the water
supply
but under the toilet it's not like i
have
you know we both have fancy toilets that
do so much more but i was like i'm gonna
buy one of these right now
and i'm gonna take it with me on
vacation that's a good instinct so what
i'd
i bought a bidet or a good instinct
and and when i i tried to hook it up at
home
downstairs so did you request permission
from your airbnb host
no i'm going to put a bidet on one of
your toilets
i'm going to leave no trace okay like a
good camper
but i was hooking it up at home and i
was missing a piece with my type of
toilet
so i had to order that piece it didn't
come in time so i did not take the tushy
on my vacation you took the accordion
but when i when i was buying the tushy
there was an add-on
for an extra 20 bucks you can get the
accordion portable
and i was like this is genius yeah i'm
genius
everybody should have i'm gonna buy this
so i bought that and i took that with me
and it's boy i'd i'd fill that thing up
and i would squeeze it so hard i really
gotta squeeze i just
don't it doesn't give me i i'm i want
the pressure that i get
yeah you cannot i can't pressure up i
jacked that pressure
all the way yeah you can't you can't
it's like a rocker i
i can feel it in my throat oh gosh
but the the bottom line is clean is
maybe a good
cheap way so clean you feel it in your
throat
i don't think that the portable bidet
not a sponsor the portable bidet is not
a good way to introduce yourself to the
world of bidets because you'll be like
this doesn't feel yeah that's not as
it's not powerful you you need a real
bidet but get
like yeah just get the tushy how much is
that how much is the one that's just the
add-on
i didn't even look at the price
it's so good you won't even care oh our
the compute the main camera just went to
sleep so we're going to finish up this
episode
in the singles the singles that's how we
talked so long we ran the battery out
of this thing we had some good vacations
man yeah we did
we no even if they were bad they're good
now because
we talked about it so much we got two
podcasts out of this
oh you want you i'm we can't make this
you know how i always want us
well we can split this up no don't split
you know what because this is a bonus
for you
the way that you you americans
just look down your noses at the idea of
bidets and you ask like
stupid questions like you so you you get
wet yes you get wet
you get clean you're taking a freaking
shower before it's like a
shower for your butthole it's not that
hard to understand you still
wipe yes first then you bidet
to get totally clean and then if you
don't have a dryer on your bidet then
you dab a little bit more
yeah but you do an initial wipe to make
sure that you're not dealing with
too much yeah right now we're first
in covid in the last in the days
let's reverse that come on america yeah
do something smart for once
i can't recommend the tushy um
enough appliance yet because hey they're
not paying me and i want you to pay me
tushy
yeah yeah tissue but i want you to pay
but i also i need to get 50
i need to test it out and i haven't done
it i just got the piece yesterday that
hooks up to my water supply
so the jury's still out on the tushy uh
but it looks it looks cool you can have
different color knobs
oh and i'll let you know if it in
in my wreck and you're right if it works
let's this was not a wreck this is a
rectangle
this is not a recommendation this is a
rectum and effect
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right hashtag air biscuits we'll
we'll talk at you next week
uh dang that was that was a marathon
it's fun to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left
and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best